probably not a coincidence that aaron
rodgers shaved off that beard that was
starting to make him look like willie
nelson he's a lot more fresh-faced and
youthful now at 37 as the green bay
packers quarterback i'm i'm exaggerating
just a little bit not quite willie
nelson but it definitely made him look a
little grizzled and haggard peter looks
good now with the cleaner face and happy
birthday aaron rodgers your birthday
present is a bad eagles team not nearly
the eagles team that went into lambeau
field on a thursday night last season
and beat the green bay packers so speed
round time let's start with that game
three seven and one eagles eight and
three packers eagles best chance at
upsetting the packers is what peter
spotting jalen hurts in the lineup
throwing change up pitches against the
green bay defense
and basically
playing every game the rest of the way
like it's a fire drill
and i've heard it said this week oh boy
you don't want to hurt uh carson wentz's
confidence even more
well my reaction to that is
i'd like carson wentz to start playing
great football he's not doing that right
now this is not a time where you put
your arm around carson wentz and say
you're our quarterback till the end of
time
this is a time when you put your arm
around carson wentz and saying we have
to do what's best for the team to win
this game
you need to understand
and there's got to be some tough love
right now i hope doug peterson does it
yeah i agree with you the best chance
for the eagles is to quit waiting for
carson wentz who's groping through the
dark for the light switch to find it he
can't find it so you have to come up
with something else and doug peterson
the head coach acknowledged on thursday
or at least it's been reported he hasn't
acknowledged it's been reported that
he's given up some of the play calling
obligations they got to shake things up
we've seen them the past couple of years
find the gas pedal late in the season
they were five and seven last year they
won their final four and they won the
division so they they roughly know the
formula when the right level of urgency
is applied and maybe that'll happen this
week i doubt it but maybe it will giants
four and seven at the eight three
seahawks the giants best chance of
upsetting seattle in their own building
is what peter
i think forcing three turnovers mike uh
i don't see them being able to play this
game on equal footing but what i do see
them able to do
is being able to pressure russell wilson
hem him in and really bother him
uh they are gonna have this is gonna
have to be a turnover game for the
giants to have a good chance
yeah keep it close find a way to keep it
close kind of that plotting effort that
we saw from the eagles for a lot of last
week's game until the seahawks began to
pull away but but just do everything you
can
shorten the game have long possessions
on offense hope that daniel jones can
find a way to play that would be a big
part of it as well broncos four and
seven at the ten and one chiefs patrick
mahomes and company in prime time on
sunday night football the good news for
the broncos is they will have
quarterbacks in this game even with
a real quarterback under center the best
chance of scoring the upset is what
peter
i mean
i don't know mike i i'd like to you
probably have to say just what we just
said about the giants
you know this has got to be a turnover
fest in my opinion for denver to have a
chance i just haven't seen it in
drewlock now maybe you say okay
durlock's going home dru lock's got a
lot to prove after the embarrassment of
last week
uh and and so but i he's not going to be
able to play head-to-head with with
patrick mahomes you know for the broncos
to win this game they've got to have in
my opinion they've got to have a
significant turnover advantage
yeah don't single cover tyree kill that
would be job number one but also the
thing about the chiefs because every
week they are playing a team that is
coming after them aggressively that
knows that this is a big game for them
it's a measuring stick game for them and
some games we see that focus slip
for the kansas city chiefs hell it
slipped after they were up 17 nothing
against the buccaneers on sunday that's
the one big flaw with the chiefs they
still find a way to overcome more often
than not
but they do lose focus they lose their
edge they lose their magic and they seem
to be better when they're playing a
great team so
you just hope that this is going to be a
week where maybe they're sleepwalking a
little bit and maybe you can catch them
flat-footed and turn it into a game like
the raiders did but you got to be able
to score points too because even on a
down day when they lose they're still
good for 30 points peter
yeah and i think i think that's why you
have to really try to force the
turnovers in you talked about it with
tyreek hill
study the patriots tape
um from the afc championship game uh
whatever three years ago
study that tape
and see if that tape shows you or two
years ago see if that tape shows you
the the differences in coverage that you
have to put on tyreek hill which is to
me justin simmons over the top on tyreek
hill almost every snap
look teams in your division tend to play
you a little more aggressively a little
more a little more tough than than the
teams you don't play all the time they
play them twice a year they face them
out in denver
one of the first games where we really
noticed patrick mahomes in 2018 and he's
down 10 points in the fourth quarter
against the denver broncos so you know
they've got a team despite their record
that has some capable players and vic
fangio a capable coach and when he has a
quarterback maybe he can he can put
together a defense that can slow down
patrick mahomes and company just enough
so their offense can score the points
necessary colts and texans get together
for the first time this year texans have
been trending in the right direction
winning a couple in a row beating the
patriots embarrassing the lions on
thanksgiving deshaun watson if he was
with a team that was a playoff contender
would be potentially an mvp candidate
here come the colts up and down at seven
and four the confounding loss at home to
the titans a team they had beaten a
couple of weeks earlier
do you have more faith in a humble colts
defense bouncing back or deshawn watson
extending his current run of greatness
to four wins in five opportunities peter
you know in my my opinion mike i have
more faith
this is this is a game that i look at
that i think is trouble for the
indianapolis colts not that i would sit
here and say
take the mortgage money and and and put
it on houston i don't necessarily feel
that strongly about it i just know
that since bill o'brien walked out the
door and i did this in my column this
week if you compare
uh
desean watson to probably the two best
quarterbacks playing right now
uh other than him
you know aaron rodgers and patrick
mahomes and and you know russell wilson
as well but if you compare him to aaron
rodgers and and patrick mahomes right
now
in the last seven weeks
he is on a par with both of them and
he's got a better passer rating than
both of them he's been more accurate
than both of them and so to me
i think this is the sign of a
quarterback playing with extreme
confidence
who's been playing with a little bit of
one hand tied behind his back because of
injuries at times
but to me i think coming off the 10 days
of rest after thanksgiving
this is i think a real
pothole game for the indianapolis colts
deshawn watson's odds according to
points bet for mvp are at plus 10 000
that means bet 100 win 10 000
if he's the mvp and the team's not going
to do well enough for him to get into
the mvp conversation but he is on the
fringes there equal with tom brady and
equal with tyree kill at plus ten
thousand odds uh i i
let's see what happens you know they
keep winning and he keeps being the one
man band especially now that will fuller
is gone for the rest of the year they've
released kenny stills he doesn't have
the help around him david johnson's been
gone he may be back sooner rather than
later but if they can just keep going if
they can and some of these other teams
are fading you never know i don't know
that nine and seven gets you in and i
don't know that they have a realistic
chance at getting to nine and seven but
it's just exciting to see deshawn watson
standing out and and it makes that job
very intriguing because there's gonna be
a very happy makes that job the most
intriguing
yeah yeah that's right mike that job
now all of a sudden somebody asked me
yesterday what's the best job out there
and i said look i understand the cap is
not great i understand you're missing
three very high draft choices in the
next two years i get it
my issue is
what does every coach what does every
general manager
what do they want to do when they start
a team or when they take a job
they want to have
a great quarterback on the roster
you can figure out everything else and
that's exactly the way i would feel if i
were eric b enemy right now or if i you
name
the the coach right now who's the most
desirable coach robert sala i you name
him josh mcdaniels i don't know who it
is but you name him maybe even brendan
staley who's my upset pick uh with the
los angeles rams defensive coordinator
whoever it is
if i'm that guy i want even with all the
front office mayhem that's the job i
want
yeah and and and that that's one thing i
would want to know and i don't want to
make this gratuitous but if i was a
candidate for the gm or the head
coaching job in houston i would want to
know where does jackie used to be fit in
my line of reporting to the owner of the
team do i report to easter bee is he
floating around as kind of an unofficial
supervisor i want to know how this
culture that he's creating affects my
job and my ability to put together the
most successful team that i possibly can
the raiders and the jets get together
last year the raiders lost 34 to three
to the jets this year the raiders are
six and five reeling after the 43-6 loss
to the falcons jets just looking for one
win unless they don't want to win and
want trevor lawrence but uh
could we see
could we see for the second straight
week and the second straight year the
raiders embarrassed
uh by a lesser team
i mean anything is possible in the nfl
but
to me this is a significantly different
jets team with a lot less fight
than it had a year ago you know it
seemed like last year on defense greg
williams defense was
was backyard brawlers and when jamal
adams was right
uh this was
a
defense that was in the teens
in the nfl in terms of a tough defense
to face
i it isn't that right now and do you
trust anybody on offense uh you know
they have a good receiving core right
now that is back
that is better than it has been but do
you trust anybody on offense to make
enough plays to beat the raiders i don't
um and again that was a shock last week
when they got blown out in atlanta i
just can't see them losing to the jets
on the road in a week that john gruden i
am positive has made it miserable to be
a las vegas raider
yeah and and i think to a certain extent
the loss of the falcons is a
disqualifying moment for the raiders
that should keep them out of the
postseason if they lose to the jets and
fall to six and six and have to back
losses to losing teams especially the
jets they're done it's over maybe the
texans do have a path to the postseason
because you can kick the raiders to the
curb before we take a break here because
we've got the show me something draft
coming up the nfl has announced the
players of the month i just want to run
through them real quickly no big
surprises patrick mahomes the afc
offensive player of the month dalvin
cook of the vikings the nfc offensive
player of the month t.j watt it could
have been jj tj what the defensive
player of the month in the afc cameron
jordan defensive player of the month in
the nfc and rookies of the month
offensive justin herbert defensive
jeremy chin first guy since 1948 to have
multiple fumble returns for a touchdown
in the same game
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports